the gyro can experience there's a few
other factors in that are taken into
consideration when people talk about
longevity and health and those are
community enjoyment friends loved ones
satisfaction with what you do for a
living how do you take those into
consideration and what do you think is
going on with those yeah these things
are definitely big so all of these
things and it goes further than that it
got a sense to like you know meditation
and yes yoga and so on everything that
relates to stress is very important in
aging it's you know it's it's reasonably
well understood that when you're in a
stressed-out state you create you
synthesize elevated amounts of certain
hormones that interact throughout the
body and in various ways accelerates the
accumulation of these various types of
damage I was talking about earlier um so
it's no surprise that there's a
mind-body relationship there and in fact
if we so people often study centenarians
people who live an exceptionally long
time right and why do they so then look
obviously because they want to find out
what the tricks are unfortunately it's
quite frustrating because there's not a
lot in common
you know some centenarians a little bit
overweight so I'm sitting there in smoke
you know it's it's it's not easy to
actually figure out what they got in
common but there's one thing that almost
all centenarians have in common which is
nothing bothers them it's not
necessarily that they have had
particularly stress-free lives the thing
is that when they encounter a stressful
situation they cope with it really well
and you know so you know the hormone
level filler thing you don't get
elevating interesting so the cortisol
doesn't rise adrenaline doesn't spike
they don't freak out or slightly for
spike for more money yes they don't lose
sleep they can handle it that's
interesting that's so it really boils
down to the effect that's going on
inside the mind in the body yeah that's
how it the body's reacting to the stress
do you meditate yourself no no I'm just
Joe anyway well you're also satisfied
well that certainly can
yeah so you don't feel the need yeah at
a physical level I have a very stressful
life I spend my life running around
airports and so on but a mental level
nacho
[Applause]